this is blues on halsted it is one of
the authentic blues bars on the north
side of Chicago I want to learn the
Chicago blues I've got about 20 minutes
then I'm going to add a spa for some
aromatherapy so I think 20 minutes is
enough let's do it you know blues on
halsted one of the great authentic
Chicago blues bars and all the legends
have played here Billy Crystal
of course Bo Derek right there and
nobody sings the blues like local ABC
reporter John Garcia you'll be crying in
your beer
we go this is very exciting I'm sitting
with Lil Ed hey Collette how are you
doing all right
good plan to use all your life a lot of
people that would say that to really
play the blues you have to gone through
a lot of hard times do you think that's
true at some point there's the time we
feel some sadness going on yeah and that
does bring out the blues because I was
worried I wouldn't be able to play the
authentic blues nothing bad has ever
happened to me ever grew up in a nice
suburban neighborhood outside my dad's a
doctor mother's a lawyer
ah nice head of hair nothing bad how do
I play the blues well you just you just
think about all the good stuff oh okay
so the Blues can also be about good oh
really so you can write a blues song
about how my car gets amazing gas
mileage good good information I have the
real Chicago blues that's what I want to
learn
with my baby turn up me now when you're
singing a song like that does it help if
I jump in with things like my baby done
left me and I jump him I think I hear a
better love you
[Applause]
let's try and jump in behind
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this guitar here is this is Pamela yes
this is nice and this one is Tanya right
here onion this is my guitar had it for
a long time it's name is Admiral
Huffington yeah and you know I always
say like it's time to whip out Admiral
huffy - that's which can sound dirty
and you have a great style complement
you you you look good and I want to get
a different look this isn't gonna work
no promises but also I'm gonna play the
blues for you what are you talking about
this means pay up that's right the music
ain't free
this hats saying I'm a badass and pay me
would you like to do that really gets
the crowd going crazy well I like to do
my back bend knees get on your knees
like this yeah and bend over backward
and bend over backwards all the way back
okay is it uncool to have some sort of
orthopedic pillow oh okay so that's not
a good idea
all right so this is a backbend I'm
doing it right now and I have to tell
you a lot of things are tearing right
now in my groin areas it could be okay
actually there's actually blood filling
my jeans right now okay I need a rest
and some water and I need some shiatsu
massage okay what else do you like to do
oh I like to walk on my toes like that
oh my God look at that
that's incredible look at that can you
play and do that at the same time I
could do that if I was being supported
by two Union guys
yeah well I gotta take that's kind of a
scarecrow look at that like a liquid
they call me the liquid snake I ever do
this I call this book I'd go rowing you
ever do that no way at the same place
sometimes I when I'm playing I like to
rub the guitar all over my body
in an erotic way it's the ladies and
some of the fellas excited
do you like to sometimes jump off the
stage is that true yes I do
yeah that's a big joke huh you got a lot
of height there if my prom is on break
cautious
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]